Hello everyone, welcome back to another episode of the Grand Prixquel Podcast where we discuss all things
feeder series. On this episode we're going to be doing a recap of the F2 and F3
Weekends at Spa, as well as the FREC weekend at Paul Ricard and British
F4 at Zandvoort last week. Your hosts today are myself, Evan, Alex and Nova.
So we get right into F2 because I think quite a lot happened there. I mean, for
Quali, the pole may seem like the usual thing, like as we said we're in Spa and
Camara put it on Pole again, but I feel like the rest of the top 10 have a few surprises
there with Inthraphuvasak on P2, Bennett on P5, and Mini having real
struggles and being quite far away from the point positions. Inthraphuvasak up that
high in P2 is again reaffirming my idea that ART is just getting a bunch of money
and that's how they're getting up there, because if you told me like three years ago that
Inthraphuvasak would be, well two years ago actually, it doesn't really matter how long ago,
Inthraphuvasak could be P2 in a Quali session –or ART actually in general—was up that high?
I'd be like ‘absolutely there’s no way.’ I was like, ART is such a weird team because on some
tracks they're just like completely a**, but especially in F3 this year they've been
actually pretty solid, and it's such a weird combination because sometimes they can do it,
sometimes they're just sh** in the back. It's F2, I'm not surprised about anything, but it's so weird.
Also Double DAMS Appearance in the top 10, which I think they're actually getting a little bit
better somehow. It's very weird, again if you told me like two years ago that DAMS was doing that
good I would not believe you, but they're improving a little bit. Also sometimes they're
pretty solid, like didn't they place with Jak Crawford pretty high last year? But then again,
what do they actually do? Like they don't do a lot of series, I think it's really only F2 and F3,
and so it's kind of weird. But we can go for the sprint because it was in my opinion a really
typical F2 thing, with on the formation lap, Beganovic kind of like halfway overtaking
I think it was Montoya and…no, it was not Montoya, but it was because Montoya slowed down very,
very heavily, and Stenshorne almost stopped, and suddenly Beginovitch was in P3. Okay,
like he did not have a lot of good luck, I feel like this weekend. I think DAMS in general did
not have amazing luck this weekend. It was great for them in quali, and then after quali everything
just went down the drain. It's very unfortunate for them, considering where both their cars started.
DAMS always got a subplot going on. Beganovic still got a podium in sprint at the very least.
That is fair actually, I was gonna say that. I only just said the DAMS being kind of bad luck
because Bilinski had a poor start and whatever, and I think Dino also had a poor start in the
feature race, but, or did he? I can't remember, one of the two. Either way, well on the sprint
race anyway, so it doesn't really matter. Another team that had once again pretty poor performance
Was Prema, where I was already surprised that Montoya made it to the top 10 in qualifying,
starting from reverse pole. You expect to get at least points, but... It was insanely funny at the
last lap, everyone was just overtaking him. He was just like, one by one, everyone just right
going ahead of him. I'm like, that's lovely. And that's just like, that is essentially Prema
In F2 and F3 right now. It's just absolutely hilarious to watch. It's insane. Imagine telling
someone like in 2023, ‘Yo, you know, both your F3 and F2 team is actively shitting the bed.’
and we would be like ‘what are you talking about?’ Oh, Prema, how you've fallen so far. But no,
Montoya's done this with every single sprint start where he doesn't seem to know how to start the
car the moment the lights are out. And it's like, you're wasting such a good, like, spot there.
I think we call that a skill issue. It's skill issue for sure. I always wonder how the conversation
goes like back at home. Like, do you think his father is like giving him tips?
JPM is so disappointed. Every single time I see JPM on the screen when the F2 on TV direction
show him, I'm like, that man is probably, like, insanely disappointed right now. And it's just,
it's hilarious to me. I'm sorry. Yeah. But like, I feel like as a father, you can't just be like,
oh, you're f***ed. You have to be like, hey, have you ever tried putting your foot down on the gas
pedal? Have you ever tried that? Like, you have to be a bit educational. Have you ever tried doing
this thing of like getting into gear first? Have you tried like, you know, going ahead when the
lights turn green, getting in your car to go? Have you tried driving? Have you tried driving?
Well, I'll get to him when I talk about FREC, but this is why I keep saying that Salim Hanna
is JPM's favorite son despite not being related to him at all. At least he's putting his foot down
on the gas once in a while. But other in other news, it was a typical F2 sprint race. Shields
caused a safety car. Bennett caused a safety car. You know, just the usual. Some drivers had
technical issues. I think it was Varrone and Mini. Mini seems to have had problems in both
qualifying and sprint, which is really bad considering he's pretty much in the title fight.
And we ended with a win from Joshua Durksen, which is incredibly interesting if you consider
the fact that -I don't know who else saw the graphic on Twitter, but if we only count feature
races, he's dead last. I was going to mention that, yeah, the fact that he has nothing.
This is just showing off the whole Invicta only being good at like, short distances.
Yeah, that's always what I say. They're the quickest in qualifying because they're super quick
on the one lap. But when it comes to actually having to race, having to overtake, oh my god,
don't let these boys overtake. They don't have that in them.
Camara’s just lucky, okay? We can tell. Actually, Kamara's just lucky half the time.
I mean, it's easy if you start from pole. Exactly.
I mean, we saw it in F3 with Camara and we're being so mean today. Oh my god, we're going to
get cancelled. Anyway, what I wanted to say, what I mostly remember from F3 and Camara’s season,
and I was like, oh my god, he won so much. He won all of, I'm pretty sure he won like the majority
of the races he won from pole position. When he didn't have pole position, he just pretty much
did not overtake most of the races. And if he did, it was like on someone who was really,
really slower because it was, you know, reverse grid. And some of the people starting in the front
who would usually only qualify P12 are handed through. It was such a weird statistic to see
his F3 season. Anyways, if we're going to the feature, it's important to mention
Beganovic's weird start because from what I saw, it was like he had a jump start, then he,
I didn't even think it was a jump start because it didn't look like he really started. It just
looked like. I think he stalled his car. Yeah, but the thing is, he first moved and then he stalled.
I mean, you can stall your car like that as well. It's like, it's like a learner- a new driver trying to
Learn manual, jump up a bit, and then you stall the whole car because you don't know when
to change your gear. Yeah. Because of that, it just looked to me like not do the usual jump start.
He also got five seconds for it. So they did call it like it did facilitate as a jump start,
I suppose, but it just didn't look like that. I mean, they're pretty strict with that.
Like they have all these cameras around. If you jump start, you jump to start and they're going to
shoot you, whatever. He's not, he did not finish the race, right? Nope. He was one of the first in pits.
He's getting it as a grid penalty in, Cody, in,
he's getting it as a grid penalty in Hungary. Wait a second, I need to get Cody.
Cody is back. I can use that graphic again. Finally. You've had it locked and loaded.
It's been there since like episode, like nine, the last time I used it and like 20 episodes later,
I can finally use it again. But we need to, we need to, we need to discuss the first lap because
there was, I mean, not a lot going on, not in F2, you know, style, but it was still
some things going on. It was like, like Camara and Tsolov contact, it was like, Inthraphuvasak’s- like in the
grand scheme, things not weird, but it was, you know, just F2. So, uh, you completely forgot about
the early crash with Mini and Bilinski where- I didn't, I just realized that as well. Like they
drive, they crash and it was a bit of a weird situation. Mini got five seconds for causing
collision. Bilinski had to DNF the race. But other than that, that crash was really irrelevant,
actually. Like it did not really impact anything except for like Bilinski, you know, DNFing, but
like it just happened, does sometimes. On the other hand, what you already mentioned with the
Camara-Tsolov contact, that one did lead to a bit of an outrage on social media. I don't know if
you guys saw that. I'm not surprised, honestly. I didn't see anything, but I'm not shocked either
way, but depends which fans it's from though. Like the nation of Bulgaria is currently trying to
start war with the nation of Brazil. Um, I'm going to be honest, if you saw all the angles of crash,
it was weird because like Camara, I mean, Tsolov was pretty much in front of him and I get that
We don't want to be too harsh with penalties and want to shoot anyone that does things like that,
But considering that Camara is kind of known for having this kind of driving style, it's just
‘Try to overtake me? Well, good luck trying.’ And I think we still give Dunne a lot of that sh**,
but I have not seen that from him in quite a few races, but Camara keeps doing these things and he
keeps having questionable situations on track. Camara is the new Dunne. That's essentially what
we’re saying here on the Grand Prixquel podcast. No, I think Dunne's problem was rather that he was
so incredibly fast, like the way that he assumed, you know, incidents to go. It was kind of a bit
stupid, but he was thinking of slower race situations, but Camara is just hardcore.
This is my position and you're not getting that. And I think I understand where it's coming from,
but for me, there's still a bit of difference. Anyways, we still have some other cars that just,
you know, did not feel like finishing the race. Mini's car was full on burning at some point, but
no one gives a f**k. Whatever.
Uh, Goethe out for whatever reason. Do we know why?
I think he had contact on that first lap. I think that was like a separate incident from the
Camara-Tsolov, Mini-Bilinski and he just contact and then his car just stopped.
There was a picture of him that I thought was really sad when he's pushing the car himself.
Always something going on with Goethe and MP down at that garage.
I feel like with Goethe, we see him out a lot. I think he's DNF'd so much this season from
what I remember. And I think part of it is the fact that MP is doing a lot of whatever,
but also he's constantly like qualifying in the midfield and having to start races in the
midfield. And if you're not a driver that's like really, um, you know, careful in those areas and
you're f**ked. Like he's not finished a race six times this season. That's quite a handful.
Crazy.
And that does not even include times where he may have had like contact or was involved in
something which he finished a race, but like his car had some issues, as I'm pretty sure happened.
If we talk about cars having issues, being destroyed, we should talk about Van Hoepen's crash.
That was, that was, I think I remember looking, I was looking at my laptop writing notes. I look
back up, I just see like, fire, oh wow, lovely. Like, sure. That was, that entire car is like done for.
There is no way that, there's no way it's a new chassis time. Like there's no way that's
going back together, I feel. If not, the Trident mechanics are working very long overtime hours
right now to get that car repaired for this weekend. Um, what caused it? Did he just like,
what caused the crash again? Cause I don't remember.
Uh, I think the problem was he lost, uh, I don't know if he lost the front or the back, but he lost
something and like the tires and he just slid over, um, the road, turned, uh, went over the gravel
like into a barrier and that was about it. But I wanted to add on, it's not even like the mechanics
really have the time to do it because this week we were in Spa, next week we're going to be in
Hungary. Like they're on the road now. They don't have the time to spend multiple days like really
fix that. So I assume it'll just be another chassis, which they have to work with.
Speaking of tires, I don't know what's up with those Pirelli tires, but they're absolutely
horrible. And F2 is still bound by them because F1 still uses Pirelli or whatever.
Those tires were f***ed after a thing was three laps and most they could do. And it was like,
it pissed me off because this just does not help with promoting strategy because if you know,
you have tires that are pretty much like qualifying cause you can only do like two to three laps on
them. It does not help with getting used to. I mean, on one hand side, it's pretty good because
that means no driver is forced to follow their team for any great strategic ideas. And we see
usually two different strategies going on. But I feel like maybe it would be better if the tires
could at least survive so long that you can change them once the pit even opens. Because
for anyone who's potentially not aware, you have to wait, I think it was like the first six or seven
laps before you're allowed to do. Six-seven! I heard it and I was like, oh my God, I f***ed myself. Before you're
even allowed to change or you can change your tires always, but before it counts as a necessary pit
stop, only that, you know, by the time everyone came in, they were like losing so much time.
The only guy that, you know, managed it was Noel Leon, who had an absolutely insane weekend.
Did we mention that? What happened in qualifying with him? I don't think so.
Anyways, so he caused a red flag, which usually means you're not allowed to be in the session
anymore. And usually a red flag causing, that means you'd like total your car or something.
But he just, you know, stalled and he went off again, which means which meant he could start
qualifying again. And Campos sent him out again, which I thought was like the right decision,
because you can always discuss later on. But sadly, the discussion didn't work for him. And
it was decided that all of his laps were disqualified and he would start last.
Anyways, in the feature race, he actually had great strategy because coming from last, he and
seemed like decided to pit from super soft to the hard before it was even allowed. So they knew
he would have to do another pit stop. Only that when he had to do another pit stop,
we had a safety car and the red flag. So he could switch to tires then and basically had
all the tires when they were in their perfect window. And because of that,
at some point he was really, really far ahead. But I don't remember when it was.
Anyways, if we want to talk more about Noel Leon, we have to talk about the fact that all of his
great stories and the fact that he would have finished the race in the points, I think it would
have been like P7. It doesn't matter because he was disqualified. Yeah, that was a whole situation.
Yeah. So what happened was the FIA, I guess, or one of his guests using a headset,
not a listening-only headset, which in normal people's terms, that's the headset, that’s the
Type of the headset with the microphone on it. And so they were saying that there was potential
that that guy who was classified as non-personnel could be relaying information to the team or
whatever. And I guess they decided to just DSQ him for that. And they also get 25 points
from the championship if it happens again. But I think in general, those are really harsh terms.
DSQing, I know it was Leon's guest from what I can gather from the docs, but it just seems harsh.
That's a whole Volkswagen Golf right there with a fine. And 25 points if it happens again, which
how can they even determine any-? I know there's a microphone on the side of the headset,
what if the microphone wasn't plugged in? But I think it wasn't in the doc that it said that the
guy or the girl- who knows? who was there was told by someone at the track that they have the wrong
headphones, but they didn't listen. I swear I understood it like that in the document by the
FIA. And simultaneously, I understand that we think it's super harsh and I still think it's harsh,
but also it's based on very specific rules. And I understand that it's a rule and it has to be done,
or next week you're going to have everyone inviting someone and suddenly the limit of
people allowed in the pit wall is broken because everyone has another guy there.
Yeah, that's fair. It's always precedent with these rules and that's just how it is.
You are right. Apparently, the scrutineer, as the document says, told the personnel or the person
to or get to put their to get that headset wasn't permitted, I should say. And apparently,
they were responsible, the microphone folded upwards. And I guess, and then they just kept
using the headset upwards. A lot of people on X have been saying that for some bizarre reason,
Tsolov should have also gotten the penalty, but it also doesn't make sense because this was Leon's
guess, I think, from what I can tell. It was the guess of Leon. I didn't see that. That was probably
just Camara fans. Like people one TikTok. Yeah, it was only for Leon because Tsolov argued that it wasn't his guest.
So they were like, OK, if it wasn't your guest, then I suppose we only have to give it to Leon.
Yeah like, why should he get a penalty because Noel Leon's guest can't behave,
I think it would have been really unfair. But have we mentioned yet the fact that Noel
Leon wasn't even on track, like he wasn't even there when that was discussed? Yeah, he had
already left the track. I honestly think he was probably going back, going just heading back home
or doing something else because like it was just Tsolov and the team manager there. So Leon wasn't
there. Tsolov was essentially representing him. So that was fun. Imagine like you're on the plane
and you get off and you hear from your boss, hey, so you just got disqualified because someone,
one of your guests was wearing a headset with a microphone on it. Thanks. Bye.
But also you have to remember the point of, hey, bro, do you have like 20,000 euros on hand?
We have to pay that in like 48 hours. Maybe call your bank
because it is in a working condition that it has to be done in the next 48 hours.
Hey, bro, do you have a whole car’s worth of money to transfer to the FIA right now?
You've got like two days to do it, but like right now? Wait. We know you're preparing for
the next weekend. I personally do not have 20,000 euros on hand. And like these are rich people,
but again, this is F2. Do all F2 drivers have 20,000 euros on hand? Yeah, I was gonna say
20,000 euros in liquid, like liquid 20,000 euros? Probably not. No, they sell their stocks in Tesla
now. SpaceX, IPO, sell the stocks in that. They probably got some crypto, sell off NFTs that are
worth five cents each. They all probably have a crypto portfolio, let's be real. They could
make money within 48 hours. I think they're doable. Turn the assets into liquid. But
next thing you see, there's just a driver selling their personal belongings on their story.
Outside the track, one of the drivers outside the track is going to be selling off, okay,
Here, uhm,  race suit, boot, helmet, everything, absolutely everything at this point.
One day that's happening. We're gonna do this podcast and one day we're gonna
hear an absolutely ridiculous story like that. Okay, to the championship standings, we have
Tsolov still leading by quite a margin on 161 points. Mini was able to
salvage at least some points. I think he finished like P6 in the feature race or P5.
He's on 134. Camara with his win is up to 125, but still quite some points down, Tsolov.
Those three, they are pretty clearly in a title fight and I think we'll see some things there.
In P4, Dunne on 108 points can still have an impact, but almost 60 points ahead,
I don't think he's quite able to chase down Tsolov yet. In P5, Noel Leon, after this horrific weekend
on 69 points, I think it's clear to say the championship will be done between the top four.
Pun intended. Quite fascinating. I'm really sad that Dunne is like 60 points behind Tsolov,
because I had him as the title or championship winner, I should say, for this season and I think
he can still do it, but he's relying a lot on top three to just not do well as well.
So it's almost over for him at this point. I think his biggest advantage is that he's pretty,
I think he hasn't won a race yet, but he consistently gets points. When Camara
DNFs, like he did in Monaco, he gets points and same goes for Tsolov obviously, and
simultaneously I think one thing that could aid Dunne in the long run is the fact that I have heard
some slight rumors that Mini could be going to Formula E, and if he doesn't go to Formula E,
saw it in the last few seasons, that would mean that he would probably not finish the season,
which means, naturally, Dunne would have at least a chance to get higher up there, but
that would depend on Mini leaving the championship.
Yeah, I mean, we've seen that with Pepe Marti most recently, I should say,
where I think he missed the last three rounds maybe of F2 when he left from
To Kiro last year or whenever it was, and we've had the same with Taylor Barnard doing the same
and whatnot, but- Zane Maloney also.
I think that's a lot to bank on your championship being won by or being in back in the fight probably
on ‘this driver's going to leave for Formula E, so therefore I now have-’ I think it's a lot,
it's a bit too optimistic for him, but- It's risky.
What I would base my expectations on is the fact that we will 100% see
some changes on the grid after Madring, 100%. We saw it every single time in the last few years
because F3 ends earlier and F2 seats get more expensive after Madrid, or usually it was after
Monza, but this year it'll be after Madrid when, you know, F2 only goes to, I think it's some Baku
where they also, like they're also in Abu Dhabi, but they're also somewhere else
if that even happens this year, but the thing is those races are usually quite a chaotic grid
and I think it's a shitty thing to bank your expectations on, but if
Rodin is still struggling, you have to get a bit desperate with it I fear.
If we're talking about teams, it's super interesting actually because in the teams
championship, we have Campos in P1 with 230 points, quite a bit off, Rodin with 166 points in P2
MP is actually in P3 with 163 points which, you know, is really good and I'm really surprised
but Invicta is only P4 with 161 points and like majority of those are done by Camara and P2 to P4
are all in the 160 points range, there's like five points separating them. We will definitely
see some-. Invicta being that low is, again, I think it's just a display of the fact that they
only are good in short distances usually or when they start from pole and well that's,
whatever we've seen obviously Camara winning on the feature race or he just doesn't do well
in sprint race or well he does sometimes or I guess, I should I'm meaning to say is that both
is that, I guess Durksen, the only of the other Invicta, not doesn't do well usually and I think
it's just again indicative of the fact that the car itself is just good enough for like quick bursts
so a quali lap, a sprint race maybe but they're not that great at feature which is where
the most of the points are which is why they're pretty low I guess in comparison. We see both
Invictas regularly in the top 10 for qualifying but usually it's Durksen then who does not do
the same you know he can gain because he usually is in a lower top 10 and then he can gain in the
sprint but he can't put that anywhere in the feature race while MP on the other hand has
Oliver Goethe as the second driver who usually struggles has a lot of retirements but he instead
of doing qualifying he if he gets points he gains from the fact that others struggle and like crash
and stuff and then he keeps it on track, and then he gets points. So I think MP and Invicta are pretty
much very similar in that extent, but we need to get on to F3. F3 qualifying was… was weird
Quali itself as a whole is just odd. How would we even start with Quali? We can discuss this now
because do we think qualifying or- maybe we should start with what happened and then discuss it
The problem in Spa is that the slipstream is and the tow is very efficient and you pretty much
need it to get a good lap down, which means drivers try not to be the first on track but they try to
have someone in front of them which means they're idiotic and then you suddenly have a picture of
every single car going down the Kemmel straight  right behind each other right next to each other. There's 30
cars and some of them are going four wide and that's not going to work, so we had a lot of
Penalties: um, Theophile Nael got a five place grid penalty for driving slowly in the racing
Line, that's the explanation that most are giving most are given and he also got two penalty points.
Ugochukwu, Kato, Sharp, Wharton, Nakamura,Bhirombhakdi and Xie, they all got three places for driving
slowly on the racing line and the two penalty points, however Ugochukwu and Xie also got three
places for leaving track without justifiable reasons. Del Pino and Garfias got each three
places for weaving in places where they weren’t meant to be, and Stromsted got five places for causing
collision, but wasn't that in the last race or like the first-? I don't know, I just think this was
necessarily qualifying, the point is as we've heard everyone was on the racing line everyone
was getting annoying, do we think we should keep F3 qualifying the way it is? Because as an example
in Monza, I don't know if we're doing it again this year but they did some years ago at least,
they separate the grid so it's only 15 cars and you avoid having 30 cars
all going down it's still with 15 cars is still ass, but like it's a bit better I saw some people
asking for one lap shootout; what do we think about all of these possibilities?
I am a much firmer believer in group qualifying, having two groups. I hope rather than one lap
shootout because then at least each group is getting enough time to maybe do two laps
two-three laps maximum instead of one lap, though you do also at the same time then obviously one
group will always be disadvantaged because oh, they have this slower like lap time so
lap time so it's I guess it's a bit hard to just- you can't, because the issue is that when you make
this qualifying system more complicated, you've got more implications like–for example I'm going
to put SuperFormula in there because it's the one category I watch, that does this you've got
Group A and Group B Qualifying One and then Qualifying two is just top six from Group A and
Group B fighting out for the top 12, but at that point now you're just putting like a lot of time
into just I guess it's just taking up too much time whereas well the current solution where it's
just everyone goes on track and whatever you do whatever is more time, it saves more time
and so I guess you know what I was saying on–okay, I would support a whole Group A-Group B sort of
thing is that the track I guess the track evolution over those two sessions because again in Super
Formula when I watch Super Formula, it's the same deal: Group A times are much significantly worse
usually compared to Group B and so, so would you say it makes more sense to keep it that way and
you just risk every driver getting sh**ty penalties because to be honest, I don't understand why
teams would even risk the penalties like I know the tow works but I think we saw it
last week, um, in Silverstone was it where–I didn't remember who it was–but they
went out pretty early did a great lap and just stayed in the whole time, it worked like
at certain tracks that also works like at some point you just gotta tell the teams from
the from the you know ‘race director, stop being a stupid b**ch and stuff’ oh my god, I'm sorry Evan,
I don’t want to be cussing the whole time, um ‘stop being dramatic and just do it good or we give you a
five place grid penalty, instead of maybe only the one or two places you would be behind if you
didn't get the tow,’ you know?’ yeah I think honestly in this case and scenario group qualifying would
group qualifying would just work the best I mean we've seen it work it's just yeah the track
evolution thing but the track evolution thing will always be a problem with group qualifying so
I didn't even remember it being that bad in both Monza and Monaco but I don't have the exact
numbers in mind right now. If it is group qualifying, and then just bag it for like a part of time of
group A then part of time of Group B and so on so forth then like whatever, I guess that is how it
usually is anyway, so I don't know what I'm talking about but the point is group qualifying I think
could work um ideally I'd rather have it be like two qualifying sessions but that adds
the complexity and time and F3 has neither of it and has cannot do complexity and has no time so
So in Sprint race, we had um Nakamura winning with uh Brando Badoer on second and Pedro Clerot
I don't know how you pronounce him uh finishing up the podium it was you know another typical
F3 race, uh Ugo and Freddie both championship leaders crashed on lap one but there was no
further action; a bit of drama, Nakamura pretty much defended pretty pretty solidly
I do think there's a lot more that we have to say about this whole thing
I guess sprint no I guess feature then, um not sprint but feature. Slater had a bad start, great! um
um I'm- I expected Slater in the Trident to be a lot quicker than what he's shown so far because
once again, he had a bad start. Um, his only advantage is the fact that I think actually
this year, Trident is only the second fastest car, the Campos seems just strongest everywhere
only that the Campos drivers don't seem to think that way because Ugochukwu again, struggled went off
at the exact same turn as he did the day before with Freddie and uh collided with his teammate
Theophile Nael and then Theophile Nael, uh had a front wing destroyed, uh then collided with a teammate
it's not good but you know at least that helped Slater get away from the pointless um
Sprint race he had we had a safety car because Yevan David stopped and what really was important in the
race for me was seeing the fact that Tuukka Taponen also struggles a lot more than I would have
expected him to and we blame MP quite a lot for that because they in my opinion have
the strongest lineup but always struggle a bit with the car but simultaneously his teammate uh
Mattia Colnaghi, he finished P4 and it was weird but also the camera is weird because we had both
Bhirombhakdi, de Palo and Barrichello not finish the race for unmentioned reasons, just you know, maybe they didn’t
feel like finishing the race, fine,  yeah I feel like with F3 with F3 we also just don't get as
many comments about anyone even DNFing we just kind of watch them fall down the order and then
in pit, retired, okay, yeah. Yeah I mean, it was the typical thing, I think um if we talk
about the championship standings it's now Ugochukwu still leading on 104 points but Slater was able to
get uh really close, he's still P2 but now on 103 points and he was unlucky to be collected into
sprint race, but simultaneously um I expected him to already be leading by some bit at this point
of the season but simultaneously the Campos is faster if only the drivers stopped, you know
colliding and stuff! It's a problem we've both seen with Nael and Ugochukwo and Nael is
is on P3 with 65 points but that is so far away from the front from Driver who I expected to be
closer at least to his teammate. In P4 we have Stromsted with 59 points also
so it's pretty, I feel like pretty crash heavy
grid and Rivera on 56 points you know at least the teams reflect what I'm talking about Campos on
P1 with 225, Trident on P2 with 169, uh Van Amersfoort 131, you know there's no big surprises here just
the fact that Campos and Trident are the clearly leading teams just um both teams get into too
many incidents. Okay so moving over to FREC at Paul Ricard, honestly Paul Ricard probably
brought the championship way closer together than any of the other uh, rounds that we had seen
however when we were doing free practice and quali there was a lot of surprises
which got me very, very scared. For quali one our top 10 looked pretty um,
Typical of FREC KNB on pole, Wheldon, Abhkazaa, Al Dhaheri, Olivieri, Gomez
which I do have to point out the Rodins were quite fast down at Paul Ricard, good for them
Saeter for G4, which has just been surprising me, that entire team has been surprising me these past
few weeks, Ninovic, Hanna and Francot actually this quali kind of ties in with what we were saying
about um group quali for any track really. Uh, this was a very odd moment where for some reason Group
A had set like not better but they had set faster quali times in terms of fastest in their group.
KNB went faster than Wheldon did for group which was interesting, considering the fact that
for Wheldon's last flying lap he was only about
what, what, what was it like seven thousandths of a second from him, it's just an odd
quali but very typical for the FREC grid that we have.
Race one pretty interesting um considering that we had uh, Olivieri and Abhkazava took up most of
the screen time with their fight for P2 and P3 and honestly pretty impressive with how Olivieri
managed to overtake, um not just his own teammate of Al Dhaheri, but also um, Abhkazava but the, the start
I would say was probably the weirdest bit for me where Wheldon was starting in P2
P2, they get off the line, Wheldon's had a pretty good start then suddenly by like
I think it was like turn two or something really early on in the lap he falls back to P3, overtaken
by Abhkazava and then a few like a few minutes later, you look back at the timing screen and
he's fallen all the way down to P5, which as we should know with Wheldon is not usual. There was
this like, uncanny loss of pace from him and the MP itself was really strong this whole weekend
and according to uh commentary and all sorts afterwards, it was, it was a team like it was a
team order to let Abhkazava through and for Wheldon to like fall back which I thought was just weird
but also quite interesting.
at some point Abhkazava also tried pushing Olivier off track which
was to me, it looked pretty blatant that he did like Olivieri basically was in the like was practically
like a centimeter away from the wall maybe he was basically touching it but it was just ruled no
further investigation which was an odd choice. But have you considered that maybe the stewards
just did not feel like investigating any more of the people? Because there were quite few
investigations and penalties already. yeah true Abhkazava-Olivieri, everything did happen in the
second half, everything else was already happening in the first half .Yeah but like they saw ‘we have
this bunch of stuff already going on how about we just don't do our job anymore?’ Okay, speaking
of penalties let's um quickly go through them considering that FREC always seems to have the
most amount of penalties: okay Munoz: five second penalty for moving before lights.
okay, Ninovic: 10 seconds for contact with Hanna. Something I want to point out about this, we are
on round six of eight. Ninovic has managed to collect nine points, nine penalty points on his
record which is so close to a race ban, and I don’t remember I think he's collected most of them from like
the first like the first two rounds-ish but it's insane how you how somebody manages to rack up
nine penalty points. I mean we've seen worse. Okay we have seen outright race bans, that is true
but nine. okay continuing penalties, Stolcermanis: 10 seconds contact with Ninovic that all happened
in the last corner, I remember watching it and Ninovic into Hanna, Stolcermanis right behind
Hanna, nearly went into Ninovic. Sano: five seconds, five second penalty, gaining lasting
advantage off track. Kostic, also five seconds penalty, gaining lasting advantage off track.
Daryanani: five seconds left track unjustifiably and then Lisle: five seconds race mode infringement
because he had Race Off prior to the race which is I think out of FREC, it's the silliest like
race mode penalties that we've seen just from these guys, it's genuinely getting so weird.
Quali two had a plot twist, okay so in the second group that went off for qualifying
quite a few of the people that we've seen be faster were in the same group which may be not
very surprised where in the last seconds or basically as everybody was finishing their flying
lap everybody basically overtook KNB's overall pole which I wasn't surprised by, but literally
last one over the line, Emanuele Olivieri just takes outright pole by basically a whole tenth
in front of Wheldon who had set pole for his group. However I think it's about three hours later-
Prior to his flying lap, Olivieri comes into pits. Three hours later after he sets his pole lap
he gets a three grid, a three grid place penalty because his car wasn't exactly at 45,
at a 45 degree angle in the pits before the team started working on it
which leads him to losing pole and having to start in P4
Seb Wheldon inherits pole, and therefore he gets to start on pole and he gets the pole positions
and I don't think I've ever heard that penalty before like for that specific reason. They hated
him because he was too quick, but I have to bring but I have to bring Robin's spirit on this whole
thing championship- um what's, what's the word? uh Going for the championship from Olivieri is on
again, we will see him go for the championship, he will do it. The fight is back on! For the honor of
Italy. I think race two really helped with that would keep the championship alive. Ye, definitely
so Race Two the order changed quite a bit actually from quali now that I'm looking at it
so top 10 on track is was originally Wheldon, Olivieri, Abhkazava, KNB, Gomez, Al Dhaheri, Chi,
Ninovic, Przyrowski and Anurag. First of all Przyrowski and Anurag towards the back in a
like a proper race is at the end of the points anyways is quite interesting to me being in an
RPM and in an ART, but then we also had the Tridents have just been fighting each other
I'm not sure why Daryanani and Kostic once again had contact and at some point during the race,
Abhkazava had been noted for a false start, like moving before the lights had gone. However,
during the race, it was called that there was no further action.
So personally as I was watching I just kind of expected nothing was going to go on, and he was
just going to maintain his podium um but then after the race, suddenly, I guess the stewards
decide to bring it back up and were like ‘actually no, he did have a false start, he gets five seconds.’
which would- which makes this the second weekend in a row that Abhkazava’s gotten a five second
penalty and Kean has benefited from it as a KNB fan, I am very, very happy about that
and probably was another point in this weekend that helped relaunch the championship title fight,
um additionally to help the title fight was
Olivieri Francot and Abhkazava fighting each other for what was basically half the race for the
P2 P3 like P4 positions basically and this time around Olivieri decides I'm gonna
oh try and overtake Abhkazava and also kind of get payback for race one
kind of looks like he pushes off this Abhkazava off the road but then the stewards are like ‘Nope
actually not’ This was also another problem that I had with FREC where Francot also retired
halfway through the race and we were told nothing about it. The entire time on the timing screen it
just says he's in pits and his name isn't like greyed out and it just shows he's like whatever
number of laps behind but for some reason it was just always one lap so I just assumed he was
still racing he wasn't, he had retired. And something I do have to compliment Olivieri on
is that his overtakes this entire weekend were just so clean and so wonderfully executed, it was
actually such a wonder to watch like coming into one corner just just behind and then he'd take
one of the lines and just do a sweep around the outside and there was never like a question of
It, it's just beautiful, I love FREC, crazy thing to say but FREC, beautiful right now. And after
his horrific, horrific weekend down at Hungaroring, Seb Wheldon manages to take a win, a pole
position and a fastest lap all in the same race. Penalties not as many this time around:
Daryanani: 10 seconds collision with Kostic, get these two away from each other, and Macedo:
five seconds for a practice start. This is the interesting bit and this is where we start
talking about championship title fight. For our top five drivers in in P1 we have KNB with 172
points, next two positions P2 and P3 we have Wheldon and Al-Dhaheri tied with 159 points, P4
Olivieri, only seven points behind 152 points and then p5 is Francot, all the way down with
with 90 points. I'm so f**king scared for this championship fight. I'm really, I think I really need to go to
Hockenheim because I'm pretty sure Hockenheim is the finale or it's like really late in the season
and I could totally do it and I think we need that live experience on here to know who wins the
Title. Yeah, and I think it'd be good if you went because out of I think all of our hosts here
you're the only, like proper neutral one. I was for Ninovic but he's been more of a terrorist,
more collecting terrorism points than collecting race win points, we take it. Ninovic and his nine
penalty points. Bu,  and we're already talking about going to races and I think it's a great point
to lead over to British F4 and Zandvoort, where I went last week already but you know we have to
keep it all together ,and I'm trying to you know, because it's already been a week, I don't remember
anything. I got really sick actually from being there. Um try to go through it pretty quickly
because a lot of the things that happened were really typical British F4. I mean Dries van Langendonck
is back on top also in qualifying majority races. You know, it was pretty good rest of the
qualifying was also typical guys but there was one great great surprise and this weekend it was
Alba Larsen qualified P9, her best qualifying in British F4 so far. It was kind of helped by the
fact that during qualifying we had a red flag because I don't remember who it was, ah it was
Mercier, who crashed and you know Zandvoort had a lot of red flags. We were behind a bunch of time
anyways all the time because there was so much crashing going on but overall it was a good thing
I would well it was chaotic but it was still solid I would say. In race one we had what I meant what I
said it was pretty typical, with Dries van Langen Donk winning the race uh Palmer being on second
after qualifying third uh fourth and Scott Kin Lindblom in P3 you know it's just the way things are
supposed to be around here Wherrel had a few problems and did not score any points which helped
DVL to get back onto- I don't think he got the championship lead in that race but it definitely
helped with the points he gained where Wherrel didn't gain any points but all races –and this one included–
were pretty disrupted by safety cars it was very little straight-up racing and Zandvoort is pretty
big so it's compared to like Donington Park up here and such it's pretty big and
very technical so there was not as much like overtaking stuff as we would usually see in
British F4, but I think race two was especially interesting to a lot of people especially for
the podium which consists of Ethan Lennon, George- it was George Proudford-Nalder right?  That's, that's like
his name because I'm pretty sure that's his name anyways, that is his name: George Proudford-Nalder.
Great and, but the one everyone was happy for, everyone was very ecstatic for: it was Alba Larsen
finishing on the podium for the very first time in single-seaters as far as I think. Um I do think
so because I know she got a podium taken away in F1 Academy but I don't remember if she got a podium
in whatever small F4 series she’s–anyways it's her first podium this season anyways and her first one
in British F4 which means a lot it means a lot to me because this is the second time running
where I'm at Zandvoort to see a female driver take a podium in British F4, we need to make this
a tradition! I would really like to see a win next year, if someone could you know commit to the whole
thing. It would be beautiful. You're their lucky charm. I'm the luckiest charm. Every single time
that I was at an F4 race in the last few years –which is only like three times– I saw a female
driver on the podium and that's a great statistic if you ask me. We couldn't talk about this early
in the year, but I was also at Nordic F4 where – I didn't even remember but I think the same weekend
um, Mille Hoe got a win, even, I think ,but I don't quite remember, it's been a few months, I
froze my ass off. Alba Larsen benefited a lot from the fact that guys ahead of her were crashing and
um, also the fact there were a lot of safety cars and she struggled a bit on the restarts
but in the end, she could hold on to that third place and it was a magnificent podium it was
also supported by Maya Weug and I wonder if the fact that Maya was around for the whole weekend
helped her perform better because it was definitely by far her best performance in British F4 so far
Do you think that having an experienced driver someone that I rated very highly like
Maya Weug around really helps drivers? I think yeah, because it's somebody who's like not only
just in your corner but somebody who's been there before, you know? So it's just like mentally, that
must also just help so much. And I think what helped was Maya's effect. I know that Alba is also
getting a bit of coaching stuff from Kevin Magnussen, but I think it's a different thing
if you're a female driver and you're used to, you know, the discrimination, the way people talk about
you and you have someone in your corner who has gone through the same things, it helps. But either
ways DVL cannot be kept from the podium, as he was still on the rookie podium for the race and is
impossible to get off that podium but he was joined by Jungling, which means for the second
year running, we also see a German guy, at least on the rookie podium, that's great for me again!
But I'm really sick and I'm still sick from being at Zandvoort. For race three we got back to the usual
things with Dries van Langendonck winning the race and the podium being filled also with Lindblom
and Palmer, it was an even more disruptive race because right as we watched around Tarzan or like
the exit from Tarzan, multiple drivers went off specifically Lindblom I didn't remember who but
he–maybe he didn't push– but like he was involved with someone else going off the track, someone
pushed Ella Lloyd off track, it was a lot going on but in the end it was a really good weekend
considering that Dries van Langendonck is back on the podium, and he's back in the lead of the
championship and we saw a great weekend, it was beautiful. I love Zandvoort, I love all of British F4,
it was a lot of fun and we are we're pretty much in the second half of the championship now
and so far, Dries is leading the championship by 179 points to Lewis Wherrell, who did not score
any points this weekend with 132 points and Theo Palmer, who had a pretty solid weekend but is also
only at 125 points and as for the rookie standings they have not been updated, but from what I see
since Dries van Langendonck keeps winning and keeps being on the rookie podium all the goddamn time
he's also doing pretty solid there, so it's a good thing. It's, it's, oh it's a nice thing
Can't keep him down. I'll just say I managed to talk to Dries van Langendonck after his
first win a short bit and I'm really antisocial but he just seems like such a nice bloke, like
there, it was really funny because for the third race, there were so many people with like Dries
van Langendonck t-shirts and like flags and stuff. Um I hope I can ask Evan if he can maybe enter
like a picture here for at least the Youtube video, and it was so crazy to see how much support he
gets because we saw a lot of support for Alba Larsen, because I feel like she's also one of those
drivers everyone knows and I'm like really happy if she does if she does well, if she's on the podium
it's like a big thing but the way people showed up and the difference in sound for when they
announced like Palmer on the podium, Lindblom on the podium, like people were like ‘yay’ but like
all right, but when DVL was announced, they were so ecstatic, and I think it's such a special thing to
see a driver like him and like recently it was announced that he is now getting also supported
by, I think,Max Verstappen in some way. Either way the point is he's doing very well, it's great to
see a young driver like him get so much support and clearly be on the great road, and pretty much
inevitably on the road to F1 and I'm excited to see what more we can see from him. Is there anything
else so we need to add to what we've seen this weekend or last weekend? I think that's it then.
I just remembered, yeah, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, um because I wanted to make a reminder and I have
to think about how I try to voice it then because I was at Zandvoort, British F4 and Alba Larsson
got her first podium, I personally–not affiliated to the podcast–but I thought that it would probably
interest a lot of people listening to the podcast–I decided to do a little giveaway
for a little Danish flag which I got signed by Alba Larsen at British F4, maybe that was also
very giving luck away and that and an unsigned MP driver card from 2025. I'm giving away both of
these things in like a little giveaway on Twitter. For that you just have to either go into my account
or the Grand Prixquel podcast account they also have it reposted, and to participate you just have
to follow the Grand Prixquel podcast on Twitter and repost my post. Again, this is not related to
the podcast ,but it's done by me and I assume people who listen to this podcast would probably
like to hear it and you can still enter into it until the 27th of July 2026, and then on the
27th I will probably, or the 28th, I will announce who has won it and I'm hopeful that I can make
someone really happy with this, because I know that especially getting closer to female drivers like
Alba Larsen who are usually uh, F4 drivers who usually you know someone you can talk to is not
able for a lot of people, because most of these only drive in F1 weekends but I'm trying to be
nice here. So I hope someone's interested in that. So I think that's it for this episode, um if you like
this episode be sure to give us a follow on our Twitter, Instagram and TikTok at grandprixquel.
and give us a follow on Spotify and Apple Podcasts under The Grand Prixquel Pod.
Next episode we'll be reviewing the F2 and F3 weekend at the Hungaroring,
Italian F4 Mugello, and British F4 Thruxton and thanks for listening.